Hello, this is Dr. Connor. It's going to make a video about your Atelier Robin machine. If you ever get this notice that says I cannot
Open connection to generator. Usually it won't have come six on there because I just changed it
Some of the things that you want to check if you can't get a connection with the generator
I never send out a unit unless it can connect to the generator
So maybe something little happened to your computer or something whatever
So always make sure that your USB port is plugged in and it's plugged in correctly in the back of your unit
Always make sure your unit is on because it's not on it won't receive a connection
Always make sure that it's switched to tube and on awks and then go back up here in your
On your computer make sure the program is not running. It's not saying running if it is hit stop
If it does still say running and you hit stop and may take up to
12 15 seconds before it actually stops because it's searching for a connection
So give it a few seconds and then go to file and then go down to
Properties because you want to see what comport. It's trying to run on
So right on comport six
well
What is this USB port is a comport six
Or is it comport seven or is this one over here that I don't have it plugged into comport six or seven
Well, I don't know. We are computer names that and it can be completely random
So if it's not receiving it must be comport seven so I just changed it to comport seven
Over here and then I'll hit okay
And hit okay, I'm trying to do this while I'm holding the
My phone and then I'm going to go hit run again
And now it's ready. It means you need a different bulb here obviously
So again, let's walk through that. I'm gonna hit stop
Let's say you're getting that dreaded
Can't find that can the comport can't find the generator
You go up to file
Go down to properties. I remember you can't do this unless it's stopped
And then you'll go and you'll look for the right comport
It's just gonna try one of them and you hit okay
In this instance this computer is this one
So I just hitting okay and then hitting run
And it's uh gonna work just fine. So
Uh
Stop again. I'm gonna change the comport again
What's the comport I'm using? I want to use comport seven
Hit okay
Now I can hit run and it's running
If I stopped it again, I'm doing it again
Change the comport
To what I just change it to or change it to six
It hit okay
Now it's not gonna run
It'll say searching for that
After it's searching for it for a little bit
And it won't be able to find it the bulbs not running
I'll have to hit stop
Remember once I hit stop it's still searching so it still says running see them right there
That still says running what's not running
Right because it's still searching so give it 10 to 15 seconds
Until that switches to run you'll also hear a little beep
Like it stopped searching
Give it a second because if I went to
Properties now at this point you'll say stop at first, but now it just beeped now you can see the switch to run
Because it stopped now I could go back to properties
I can switch my comport
Back to comport comport just means your
Communication port whoops I switch it to six again
Switched it to seven
Again, hit okay
And then hit run again
And now it's running
Hopefully that helps and this is just something your computer does
There's nothing we can do about that
Your computer names your communication ports
It just is what it is there's the and sometimes your computer will
Forget the communication port that this is connected to
It's just it's something that you have to deal with with computers unfortunately there's nothing
Can anybody can do about that all right hope that helps